It's delicious!
They are treats from the landlords.
I got them as a thank you gift
for watching their place.
I've never had anything this delicious!
Thank you, Kotaro!
These are thanks for the daifuku earlier.
Sorry to keep you waiting.
This is green tea.
Warm green tea is the best
with Japanese sweets.
Yeah! It enhances the sweetness, right?
So, why are you in my room, Sir Karino?
I didn't invite you.
That's right!
Well, I take care of you quite a bit,
so why can't I stay?
I did not ask you to take care of me.
But just the two of us
can't eat all of this.
Maybe it's fine to have Karino sometimes?
Right?
I'll bring some to Sir Tamaru later too.
Oh, that's good.
Mr. Tamaru might cry tears of joy.
That's true.
-Where are your manners?
-Oh.
Manga artists need to keep up
with current news, you know.
MIZUKI RE: I WAS WRONG
MEET WITH ME. I WANT TO TALK.
DELETE MESSAGE?
This anime has finally become a movie!
Tonosaman The Movie!
The Return of Tonosaman!
Do not go to the Terakoya
without breakfast!
You must do your homework!
Children should run around energetically!
Help me, Tonosaman!
We've kept you waiting!
Tonosaman The Movie!
The Return of Tonosaman!
You can collect Tonosaman cards
at theaters!
Tonosaman!
They're making this into a movie?
Amazing!
Kotaro, you like it that much?
Yes! Since I strive
to become like Tonosaman.
I want to emulate
that unyielding iron will
and unbeatable strong heart.
I need to become strong like Tonosaman!